speaking of dysfunction chris
in cleveland
everything is turning around but i don't
know how much of this you saw and fry up
colin remember last year colin coward
and and baker mayfield kind of went out
a little bit there was that goofy take
about him not celebrating with his
teammates after a touchdown remember and
and and and i thought mayfield was great
he he he took it he's got a way of of
conducting himself and a way of
communicating that is well beyond his
years he gets it he's mature he's poised
sure and what he says makes sense and uh
i i mean has that been your impression
of him because that sure has been mine
from the get-go that this guy just knows
what to say and when to say yeah no
exactly right i've been uh a big fan of
his really from two years ago uh when he
was at oklahoma i mean first of all yeah
some of the celebration stuff oh the
ohio state fl you know the the planting
of the oklahoma flag in the middle of
the ohio state football field uh again
hey we're talking about young kids here
young gentlemen okay who are still
learning their ways in the world can be
a little emotional at times but nothing
malice there i mean baker mayfield yes
has added juice to an organization
with moxie and charisma to which i've
never seen before honestly it's it's
really it ranks up there with one of the
better transformations of a culture of a
team through a young quarterback that
i've ever seen mahomes is special but
mahomes did it with on the field i feel
like baker mayfield did it with not only
on the field but the guy he is in the
locker room and we've heard it from not
only just the players but coaches who
wanted to coach there this year because
of baker mayfield and we heard it coming
out in the drafts which tells me it's
very real the person the leader the the
chara the charismatic values that he
carries must just kind of bounce off and
i've met him before and i can see it
he's got a great way about him
what we're looking for in quarterbacks
is natural leadership you either have it
or you don't and mayfield has it and
that planning of the flag in the field
it gets your players excited and they're
more likely to follow you and they're
more likely to listen to you and they're
more likely to do what needs to be it
does to win your approval in those key
moments right yeah when when the game is
on the line and you know your
quarterback who you follow who is your
leader is going to be disappointing you
you're more likely to get your job done
that's the way it works and that's all a
preface to
what happened last week when colin
coward decided to poke the brown's bear
again
and argue that it potentially is going
to be a messy in cleveland in part
because odell beckham's not happy in
cleveland he's not happy look at him
does he look happy this thing has a
chance to be an absolute mess freddie
kitchens with these egos and these stars
i can tell you i have this as well
sourced as i can have it on odell
beckham he didn't want to go to
cleveland he wanted to go to la now
he'll make it work but it wasn't his
choice so baker mayfield responded via
twitter to colin coward come to
cleveland and ask odell if he actually
likes it just because you say you have a
source doesn't mean you're not full of
bs and while you're at it come see if
i'm a baby so
i'm it's uh
yes yeah he's bigger
if i was calling coward i probably would
not go to cleveland right now but uh
that look that's the way because i i
think there is a chance this could all
fall apart and there is a chance that if
they get off to a rough start freddie
kitchens may be in over his head that's
where baker mayfield's leadership
abilities come into play and he's
already doing what he has to do chris to
hold everything together yeah that's
right he's publicly defending his player
already to where he doesn't have to
answer these some of these questions
i'll answer for you odell beckham jr
and get this started that way um again
colin cowherd i got a lot of respect for
him i certainly do i'm a fan of his now
do you know again i don't think he's
throwing out there anything we all
didn't know i mean there was always
rumors that odell beckham jr wanted to
play in la i think that's very real and
yes i think if odell beckham jr was
given his way yes he would have gone to
an la team maybe the ram certainly but
that wasn't the case uh he went to
cleveland i think he was in shock at
first i think that's more what colin
cowherd is talking about i mean odell
beckham jr has been the man for a long
time he was getting recruited as one of
the top receivers and in high school
football lsu thought he was the man then
he's had lsu he is the man and of course
the nfl is telling him hey we think
you're the man too you're going to be a
first round pick he goes to new york all
he's been told about is you're a star
you're the man you're maybe one of the
greatest receivers we've ever seen um so
he's putting another stratosphere he's
never not been wanted this was the first
time in his life where a team said yeah
we don't we don't like you that much or
we we want to just move along with you
so i'm sure that took an adjustment
period for odell beckham jr plus even if
you don't love a place it's never easy
just to pack up and leave you do have
you know connections and friendships and
things like that that play a part of it
to where yes if you're a young man who's
26 years old like odell beckham jr
oh you know a lot of these emotions and
things go through your head but i think
he is going to be very happy and he is
happy to be in cleveland because he
knows he's got a chance now to be put in
a position where he can show everybody
what he's really all about on the field
the best receiver in football and i
think he knows he's got a quarterback
and weapons around him that can take
some pressure off of him
and part of what he had to get his brain
around chris i believe is the idea that
at a time when antonio brown got to
engineer his next destination right and
tone uh odell beckham just got passed
off to whatever team the giants could
get the best return from without regard
to odell beckham jr wanting to go there
or not wanting to go there and you know
one of the wrinkles that continues to to
be
up
developed is this idea that the 49ers
were a very very real suitor for odell
beckham jr that was something i heard
right at the end of the regular season
the 49ers are going to make another play
for him and they did the giants wanted
the second overall pick in the draft
there was a report from espn over the
weekend that the 49ers were trying to to
get the number six pick back in exchange
for the two and more stuff on top of it
and while all that was happening the
browns decided we better make a move and
the browns made their move and they got
their deal done so it was that 49ers
interest that in a roundabout way opened
the door for the browns so i guess if
odell beckham jr ends up not liking
cleveland he can blame the 49ers because
it was that effort to get him to san
francisco that created the opening for
john dorsey to get him to cleveland yeah
i mean it's certainly seen that and the
talks of the kevin zeitler olivier
vernon trade and all that at least jump
started some conversation between
gettleman and john dorsey here's my
question to you though to me
okay if you know san francisco wants
odell beckham jr which was rumored to be
for the last two years really okay
why
did the new york football giants once
they got a trade offer from the
cleveland browns not call the san
francisco 49ers or other teams that they
viewed as interested and not say hey
we're being offered this do you want to
come up with your trade offer to me that
was the thing when my brain went i don't
even understand that why would you not
call another team who you know has been
very interested to see if maybe they
won't give you more now that there's a
better trade on the table uh that didn't
make sense to me
i have an answer for you okay
and and i'm going to answer your
question with a question yeah back when
your dad back when your dad was playing
for the giants who was the team that the
giants hated more than any other yeah
that's right that's right the san
francisco 49ers i mean yes at topical
value that seems that seems like it
could be correct the nfc team that they
could be their rival and they just
didn't want to deal with it i can buy
that if that's the truth
yeah i mean there's a chance that you
play the 49ers every single year as long
as you finish in the same spot in your
division as they finish in theirs you're
playing them every year and every third
year you're guaranteed to play them and
every single season you're competing
with them either for wild card births or
for playoff positioning if both are in
position to win their divisions so for
the same reason that the steelers would
have preferred to get antonio brown out
of the conference they weren't able to
do it they at least got him out of the
division and kept him away from the
patriots the giants would have loved and
did love i think getting
odell beckham jr out of the conference
all together yeah they'll only see him
once every four years and maybe if they
both get to the super bowl they'll have
to deal with them that would be a good
problem for the giants to have because
that would mean they are in the super
bowl so i think that i think that's why
ultimately at the end of the day they
they uh they didn't go back to the 49ers
and say hey we have you know this this
and this from the browns it was the
first round pick a third round picking
gibral peppers do better and we'll send
them to you so uh now and here's the
thing because odell beckham jr handled
his business differently than antonio
brown he didn't even know what was going
on right because if he had known what
was going on
who knows what he would have done i
don't want to i don't want to incur
baker mayfield's wrath here but
you could make the argument that if
beckham knew that there was a chance to
be traded to the 49ers versus the browns
he very well may have said you know what
yeah i'd like to play with jarvis landry
and baker mayfield but i'd rather play
in san francisco and he never had that
opportunity no well but but he did i
mean he did have the opportunity because
he could have made life very hard on
both teams here if he didn't wanted this
to go down so that to me would be the
context club or a colin cowherd or
anybody out there to go
no if the guy really didn't want to go
to cleveland he would have gone okay
nope you know add add 30 million dollars
more to my contract or whatever it may
be made some absurd contract demand to
where the trade would have fell through
i'm only going to go to cleveland unless
i get another 25 million guaranteed
whatever that may be whatever that
number i'm just throwing it out there
for argument's sake right now to me he
still had that power so he decided you
know what okay this isn't easy i'm gonna
have to leave new york and leave a bunch
of teammates and friends that i like in
the locker room but i think he saw at
the end of the day you know what i'm
gonna just take this trade because damn
it i've seen this baker mayfield and i
know jarvis landry and this cleveland
team's got some special players i'm
gonna go be a part of this
and
and and be happy and maybe he will ask
for more money but he's gonna do it the
right way here and be part of the team
and not make a big deal about it and not
be like antonio brown which again i
don't like when odell beckham jr and
antonio brown get lumped together
because i think they are two different
people and and odell beckham jr's let's
say list of issues he's had with his
team is far less than the issues antonio
brown's had with his team
but chris here's my point and you've
proven it in a roundabout way okay odell
beckham jr did not get an opportunity to
pick between the two because they didn't
give him a chance he didn't know what
was happening and by the time the deal
was done he was backed into a corner
where his only alternative to happily
going to cleveland was being antonio
brown see they were by not including him
in any of this process and telling his
agent oh we're talking to the 49ers
we're talking about by cutting him out
entirely they put him in a position
where when he first found out about it
his only recourse other than just taking
it was to be the kind of guy that
antonio brown has been and that's the
kind of guy that odell beckham jr
aspires not to be he doesn't like to
create these messes he doesn't like to
poke his finger in the team's eye
remember two years ago when he was
staying away from offseason workouts he
wouldn't say why he didn't even want to
take his concerns about a contract
public then so i think the giants took
advantage of his nature and it's a good
nature but they took advantage of it by
getting the deal done and putting him in
a spot where his only way out of it was
to do something he's not wired to do
yeah okay i can buy that i think you're
right by that too they use that against
them certainly it's not in odell beckham
junior's nature to be that kind of guy
certainly i'm just trying to say i think
if he was totally i hate this move i
don't want to be in cleveland i think he
had it in him to be an antonio brown
like character and maybe draw that line
in the sand but i think he saw enough
positives in this one to go okay yeah
whatever i might not be this might not
be the number one destination but i also
like the things that are going on in
cleveland i'm gonna accept that and try
to go and further my hall of fame career
potential uh there with baker mayfield
and company
i i think that that helped but the last
thing i think oto beckham jr was going
to do in that spot when he's already
being dumped by his initial team and
there's this lingering perception that
he's a diva and he's a problem and he's
this and he's that you turn around and
prove it all by saying sorry i i'm going
to play the antonio brown no to buffalo
card and say no to cleveland i'm not
going to report or i'm not going to and
that what could ultimately what could he
have done and that gets back to the
steelers trade what could this what
could antonio brown have done you trade
the guy you trade the guy he either
shows up or he doesn't and if he doesn't
time to pay back a lot of money and
consider yourself retired from the
national football league all right maybe
kirk cousins should retire from doing
pregame speeches he's he's he's done it
in high profile spots with the vikings
it hasn't worked he did it for michigan
state on friday night and comes saturday
always goes back to kirk cousins for you
always i didn't make the outline today i
didn't make the outline i'm just reading
what's on the page
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports